la première fois que nous nous sommes rencontrés, elle s'est opposée à moi, elle
semblait si sûre que j'étais sûr que c'était
si j'avais mystérieux il y a quelque chose que
vous aimeriez m'aider quelque chose que vous
aimez connaître votre femme vous savez
tout
pourriez-vous m'aider avec quelque chose que vous
ne ferez pas  dis à tout le monde
bonjour nous allons t'appeler lily je veux
te dessiner Lily nous devrions sortir
ce soir
donne leur quelque chose de différent Lily
tu es exquise tu es différente de la plupart des filles je sens que
je devrais demander ta permission pour je
histoire
excentrique ce qui s'est passé hier soir il y en
a eu un autre quand je n'étais pas moi il y a eu un
moment maintenant c'est juste idiot mais le seul
n'existe pas nous jouions à un jeu
quelque chose
il s'est égaré a besoin d'un ami
laisse moi aider je pense que les pensées de Kelly  Je
rêve de crème qu'elle est toujours là J'ai besoin de
mon mari la nuit il tient mon mari
Rob avez-vous raison le fait est que je crois que le
temps où une femme et je la crois à la
chirurgie n'a jamais été tenté avant que
vous soyez en vie cela pourrait vous tuer c'est mon
seul  espoir  ce n'est pas un corps
je dois le laisser partir
je t'aime parce que tu es la seule
personne qui a donné un sens à moi
il m'a rendu possible
toi